مرحبا بكم معالي الوزير مرة أخرى أريد فقط
التأكد من أن المشاهدين يفهمون أن
السلطة الفلسطينية كانت
معارضة لحماس لذلك أنت لست
تابعا لحماس بأي شكل من الأشكال أنت تمثل
السلطة الفلسطينية أه التي
تسيطر على أجزاء من الضفة الغربية كل
ما قال ماذا  هو رد فعلك على ما
رأيته حتى الآن
جيدا أولا وقبل كل شيء أنا لست جزءا من
السلطة الفلسطينية في واقع
الأمر أنا أمثل
حركة فلسطينية ديمقراطية تسمى
المبادرة الوطنية الفلسطينية وهي غير سمينة
وغير حماس ونحن أه نحن  'أنا بالطبع
لست تابعا لحماس ولكن أعتقد أن
هذا الوضع الذي تطور هو
نتيجة مباشرة لاستمرار
أطول احتلال في التاريخ الحديث
الاحتلال الإسرائيلي للأرض الفلسطينية
منذ أه 1967 هذا 56 عاما من
الاحتلال الذي تحول إلى
نظام أبارتي
أسوأ بكثير مما كان سائدا
في جنوب
أفريقيا، نعم ربما حماس لم تعترف
بإسرائيل ولكن السلطة الفلسطينية فعلت وفعلت السلطة الفلسطينية
ما لم تحصل عليه
منذ عام 2014،
ولم تجتمع الحكومات الإسرائيلية حتى مع الفلسطينيين وما
ترونه  اليوم هو رد فعل على عدة
أشياء، أولها هجمات المستوطنين الإرهابية
على الفلسطينيين في الضفة الغربية،
والتي طالت بالفعل 20 مجتمعًا في
عملية تطهير عرقي، 248
فلسطينيًا قتلوا على يد
الجيش الإسرائيلي والمستوطنين في الضفة الغربية،
بما في ذلك 40 هجومًا على الأطفال.  على
المقدسات الإسلامية والمسيحية من
قبل
المتطرفين الإسرائيليين وكذلك إعلان
نتنياهو أنه سيصفي
الحقوق الفلسطينية والقضية الفلسطينية
بالتطبيع مع
الدول العربية وتجرأ حتى على الذهاب إلى
الأمم المتحدة وحمل في
الأمم المتحدة خريطة إسرائيل التي
شملت كامل الضفة الغربية كل
غزة كل القدس وكذلك
مرتفعات الجولان أعلن ضم
الأراضي المحتلة لذلك بالطبع
يلجأ الفلسطينيون إلى المقاومة لأنهم
يرون أن هذا هو الطريق الوحيد  لكي
يحصلوا على حقوقهم، السؤال
هنا لا يتعلق بتجريد
الفلسطينيين من إنسانيتهم ​​كما يحدث ووصفهم
بالإرهابيين، بل يتعلق بطرح
السؤال لماذا تدعم الولايات المتحدة
أوكرانيا في محاربة ما يسمونه
الاحتلال بينما هنا
يدعمون المحتل الذي يواصل
احتلالنا.  لكن دعني أسألك إذا كان
هذا هو القياس الذي ترغب في استخلاصه أم أن
ما تفعله حماس هناك
يستهدف
المدنيين الإسرائيليين النساء والأطفال الجدة إنهم
ليسوا أه هو هذا
ليس إرهابًا كلاسيكيًا أليس كذلك
الإرهاب الكلاسيكي إنهم لا يقاتلون
الحكومة الإسرائيلية، إنهم يقاتلون
الناس العاديين، هذه إحدى الطرق لصياغة الأمر ولكن
هذا ليس صحيحًا. أعتقد أن حماس هاجمت بشكل أساسي
المؤسسات العسكرية والعديد من
المنشآت العسكرية ومعظم
الأشخاص الذين اعتقلتهم وأخذتهم
قبل الحرب.  أسرى الحرب هم عسكريون
لا أقبل أن يعتدي على أي
مدني أه لا أقبل أن
يعتدي الإسرائيليون على مدنيينا لكن أنظر
ماذا تفعل الطائرات الإسرائيلية الآن في
غزة إنهم يقصفون المنازل
ويهدمونها بالأرض وأنتم على علم بذلك  لقد
أظهرت ذلك على
شاشتك أه شقق كاملة
مباني كاملة مباني شاهقة تهدم
إلى الأرض ونحن
بالفعل نبلغ أه تلقي
تقارير عن عائلات تقتل أه
تسعة أشخاص في عائلة واحدة 10 أشخاص
في عائلة أخرى  بما في ذلك
الأطفال، لا أريد أن يتعرض أي مدني
للأذى على يد الفلسطينيين أو
الإسرائيليين، ولكن السؤال هو كيفية إنهاء ذلك، هل
سينتهي الأمر بمهاجمة قطاع غزة في
مرة أخرى شنت إسرائيل بالفعل
خمس حروب على غزة
استمرت إحداها 51 يومًا ودمرتها؟  كل
هذا لم يوقف حماس لم توقف
المقاومة هناك طريقة واحدة لوقف أي
عنف وهي إنهاء
الاحتلال الإسرائيلي وهذا لكي
تكون الولايات المتحدة عادلة، لا يمكنها أن تقول إن
لإسرائيل الحق في الدفاع عن نفسها
لكننا  ليس للفلسطينيين
الحق في الدفاع عن أنفسهم، دعوني أذكركم
بقضية شارين أباك التي
لم تكن فلسطينية فحسب، بل كانت أيضًا
صحفية مسالمة جدًا،
وقد قُتلت برصاص قناص إسرائيلي، وإذا تم توجيه الاتهام إلى أي شخص، أو تقديم أي شخص
إلى المحكمة  لم يُقتل أيضًا 52 صحفيًا آخر، حيث تم
إطلاق النار على مقدمي الإسعافات الأولية لدينا على أطبائنا،
ويجب أن يتوقف هذا الأمر، والطريقة الوحيدة لوقف ذلك
هي أن تقول لإسرائيل إن عليك احترام
القانون الدولي، وعليك إنهاء هذا
الاحتلال غير القانوني وقبول
الفلسطينيين كمواطنين.  البشر متساوون